good to have l.j newsome back on the
mountain so he will fill up the strike
zone pretty good fastball 92 miles an
hour curve and change to go with it now
the stretch here comes swinging the
ground ball to third there's nobody
there they were shifted and that's a
base hit to left field he didn't even
hit it that hard
and the giants have two men on with
nobody out and here comes wilmer flores
all the way swinging a shot to third
diving stop by seeger from menia thrown
to second base and it's in time to get
dickerson there
holy smokes what a play by kyle's secret
third taking a hit away from flores and
turning that into an outed second on
dickerson first and third for the giants
with one away no score donovan solano is
up now a swing ground ball into the hole
and into left field that's a base hit
solano comes through in the clutch as
yastrimsky comes in to score
and it's one to nothing giants
true smiley no record on the year at 292
era a couple of stars for him he's
pitched out of the bullpen a couple of
times
drops this one and that is not a catch
by de bonk
good sell
but it was wrong it's a base head
there's a rocket up the middle base head
kaylee indeed boy he put some
smoke on the water with that one man oh
man
he's not able to move crawford up or get
him in
and here comes mauricio duval
line to left lopes back loves is going
to play it off the wall crawford
is headed home the throw to second
however is going to be in time
and dubon is out but crawford scores
it's two nothing
nice play by lopes to get the carol back
up we expect you to be out there in left
field so alex dickerson could pick you
off line drive base hit down the left
field line
lopes is gonna pick it up and dickerson
has got his second hit to the opposite
field
here's belt
belt hits a high drive out into triples
alley can anybody get there they cannot
it's gone belt way out into triples
alley
it's a two run home run and it's four
nothing giants and up comes evan
longoria longoria drives one down the
left field line toward the corner it is
gone
up over the car and right out towards
the ambulance
in the tunnel
so longoria takes newsom deep his sixth
home run five-nothing giants
now he's pitching well
he's only given up two hits in the first
two innings he's got four strikeouts
here's his 2-2
and that one is in the dirt but irvin i
think he swung he did bill miller didn't
even have to ask he said that's a swing
strike three
four straight strikeouts for smiley and
the curveball is just nasty here's a
curve swung on and missed strike three
drew smiley two more strikeouts in that
third inning and he's got six now
through three against the mariners
yaski high drive left center field lewis
on the move still on the move he's not
going to get it it's off the base of the
wall they're going to wave in dubai
yashrimsky's got a double no throw and
it's six to nothing
dickerson's got another hit and another
rbi it's seven nothing he's three for
three
he got a pitch out over the play a 3-2
fastball challenge
he is
not getting any cheap hits either
there's a bullet
lines it into center field he's got a
base hit
line drive right field coming in and
knocking it down as irving everybody's
going to move up a base it'll be a base
hit for solano
after the solano hit the bases are
loaded
sadler ready to go for the pitch
mongoria takes and goes by the catcher
to the backstop a late break by
dickerson but it doesn't matter he's
going to come in to score
eight to nothing giants
bring up ty france
it hard eats up crawford base hit
well he wanted to bounce it but instead
it's in the middle of the plate
there's the ball ripped left field not
to get it seeger coming around to score
mariners on the board on a horrid hit
doubled by luis terence he's on in
relief and irving trying to get to him
3-2 pitch bases loaded two outs well
four there's an rbi
for philip irvine his third and the
mariners have a second run
and he lives
3-2 pitch
walk them wow mariners will take it
rb after jp is 16th
come in and walk three consecutive
hitters that'll do it for him gabe
kepler's seen enough
for crawford the giants have not had a
hit have not had a base runner since the
fourth inning crawford drives one toward
right center field lewis sprinting over
still going and it is up and gone into
the mariners bullpen
brandon crawford goes deep
nine to three giants he struck out eight
guys and that's the ball game
so game one of this short two game
series goes to the giants
and they win it by a final of
nine to three